I said I'm gonna not move from here all
right hello welcome thank you for
joining me for this talk machine
learning in the browser and I'm really
happy that we could like start with some
fluffiness today and gonna end with some
fluffiness in this room so I'm really
really proud of that
so for those who don't know me yet oh
this is not working
oh wait because I turned it off yes this
is me hello yes please come in hi no
take your time
all right so this is me this is actually
not me so there's a company called Lian
Li and they've basically be haunting me
my entire life because people my friends
come up to me who are also in the
industry sometimes and they're like do
you know of this company that's named
Lian Li so like this is a friend of mine
most recently was like haha I was a
computer and like I was like okay I'm
gonna be super polite and just like it
and he liked it himself again like he
liked his own post that he posted to my
timeline and he was so happy with his
post that he commented on it again with
a smiley face so this is basically my
relationship with the company Lee and
Lee so they've been haunting their whole
life like I said and I want to asked you
to help me with something this is the
situation on Twitter right now I have
I'm shy of a hundred and ninety
followers 191 as soon as I hit 892 I'm
gonna ask Twitter to give me the
checkmark and that will be the first
step when people start asking them like
do you know the speaker Lee Anne Lee and
they're like oh of course we do like
we've been in this business for thirty
years now so yeah please follow me on
Twitter or on github or on mass I have
three followers of macedon so if you
could like follow me there that would be
great
I don't think Lee Anne Lee is on there
so I might get like a checkmark there
just like that so yes that was the joke
the introduction joke something else I
do I'm a software engineer at pnina
solutions it's a company doing cloud
native consultancy based in Amsterdam
it's really not that interesting I'm not
gonna talk about my company because
that's my day job during the night or
any other time of day I am a machine
learning enthusiast and by that I mean I
have no education actually on machine
learning I just did a course on Coursera
which I highly recommend is like a
12-week sucking out your soul kind of
like super math intense course but it's
like at the others end you're like okay
I did something with my life
so highly recommend this course I'm
gonna show you I think I have a link on
the slide later so okay let's talk about
machine learning why do we want to do
machine learning I think who hasn't
heard of machine learning yet okay well
maybe other way around who has heard of
machine learning
okay that's most okay so for this to be
makes sense I have to take we have to
take a look at how s expert system words
so expert systems is what you built when
you do conventional coding and the idea
is kind of that you have a solution and
the solution is your code you have a
problem trying to find a solution you
write this code as a solution and for
that you kind of need like a person it
was usually a developer and the
developer has to maintain the code write
the code expand the code so everything
kind of funnels to him and for him to do
a good job he has to do things like read
documentation like use third-party
libraries maybe or maybe has to talk to
the main expert
but the important thing here to take
away from the slide basically is that
everything goes to this one person and
he has to have a perfect understanding
of the system now if we look at machine
learning it's kind of different
so the solution in machine learning is a
model the model it's a statistical model
so everything's kind of represented in
numbers and there are no like if you
didn't implement this edge case where
there's no really implementing of
educators it still works it doesn't
break it just gives you maybe like a
weird number and the model is not built
by hand by a developer it's just spit
out by code by a machine learning
algorithm so you run an algorithm and it
gives you a model in the end explained
to you and for this to work basically
for this code to run efficiently or to
do what it's supposed to do you need
some data and you may need some kind of
like data or machine learning experts so
these data ml experts do not necessarily
need to be domain experts although it
does make sense for them to understand
the domain but mainly they need to
understand the statistical basically
behavior of this pattern that they're
trying to learn and adapt to so
everything in the end kind of hinges on
the data the data has to be the right
amount the right format and yeah that's
kind of the our job here in machine
learning um so machine learning
basically the kind of the way it works
is pretty simple it's like how we learn
as well for one there's experience you
need experience that's the number of
data points so like you have like
different kinds of data points that
represent different you know instances
of the behavior you want to basically
adapt to and then the other thing the
same thing how we learn is repetition
that's basically our number of training
iterations so you were gonna have to
take the same data points and then just
train them a lot of times and by
repeating you kind
learn pattern behind it so pretty much
this is kind of how we imagine people to
learn as well
right then the other thing that people
have already asked me about like why
does everything have to be JavaScript
like can't you just not do that in
JavaScript yes good point you could also
not do it in JavaScript no well there
are some arguments that I could make for
client-side machine learning and I think
you could think of some as well for one
like speed not everyone lives in like a
first world country some of us live in
Germany where the internet speed is not
always that great and then maybe you
don't want to wait like two minutes for
the server to answer you with the
prediction or
get from it then the other thing is
availability again if you live in
Germany you don't always have internet
so maybe you just can't connect to the
server and so that maybe you want to do
the prediction on your client on your
website or on your phone and then the
third argument that I could bring this
security so maybe you don't want to send
your images to a third-party server to
train on it and then predict something
maybe you just want to do everything on
your phone or on your own client should
have more control over your data so all
these arguments I think are valid enough
to see effect you could build something
with JavaScript so it runs a new browser
right all right I want to try to explain
the basic principles of machine learning
to you and for that I think the best way
is to think of an example that makes
sense and then try it should translate
like those really mad C terms to things
that you know we all can understand all
right and the example that I picked is
complementary colors so the idea here is
to input a specific color which is RGB
channels so we're inputting three values
which is the value for red green and
blue and then we're outputting we're
trying to predict the
complementary color complementary color
in case you don't know it's basically
the opposite color of the color spectrum
yeah you are like no one's totally lost
here good alright so let's talk about
terminology for a while because I'm
gonna probably switch back and forth
between the machine learning words and
normal words so I'm gonna like do some
like simple diagrams so we can all be on
the same page when I expert explained
later on so first we have our input an
input it B or color the color we want to
do the complementary color prediction on
we pass that input into like a function
something like a function and then we
get an output that is the basic idea of
any system right if we were to do it not
with machine learning but with expert
system we would also have something like
that now if you look at like how we do
it in machine learning the inputs become
our features and in this case we have
three features because we have like
value for read a value for a green and a
value blue then the function would be a
network and like the network like it's a
network of nodes right and each net node
is already a function but like the
entire network would be like like a
total like a function of functions if
you know what I'm getting here but we
can look at it for now is like one
function we pass something in and then
we get something out and the output
would be our prediction now M network
and prediction have the same color here
because the prediction is always
dependent on a specific network if you
in if we put in the same values in the
exact same network you would always get
the exact same prediction now if you
want to like if you're starting with
machine learning and starting with a new
network usually your prediction is
pretty crummy and in the beginning so
what we kind of need to train is to also
know in this case what our desired
output would be what is the color that
we do want it to predict and this is
called the target this is what we want
to predict right and so in this diagram
what I wanted to show kind of is that
the blue and the green ones this is the
data that we actually need to do the
training because then the network and
the prediction is something that we're
going to come up but we're gonna train
by ourselves but we need to have like a
good data set that's the input and the
target or the features in the target
this is just important for you to
understand so a complementary Carlos is
actually a really good example because
we don't have to do a lot of data mining
we don't have to go out and you know try
to find like labeled data it's pretty
easy to just generate data on the fly
when you just want to try stuff out so
this is kind of how our input generation
could look like we just basically have
to generate a random value between 0 and
255 and then you know do that three
times put in an array that's basically
one random color and we just do that
like 10,000 times for 10,000 data points
and then there's a function for the
output which is the so this is our
desired output right I didn't put the
full function there but there's a link
to Stack Overflow if you want to check
it out how to compute our complimentary
colors just know that in the end you
again have an array with values between
0 and 255 all right to make it kind of
easier to understand what we're getting
at here how we're trying to build this
thing I'd created this nice handy
checklist so first thing we need data
got that next thing kind of need a
network thingy
to make a prediction right when we have
that doing something awesome in the end
it's gonna be awesome
that's all we need to know for now in
your network then do something awesome
gonna be awesome right the nice thing is
that we don't have to implement every
network by itself there's like Google
doing stuff like deep lunges and
different yes
it is based on tensile flow I don't know
if any of you have ever heard of tensile
flow yes I see some heads nodding and
fingers going up yes cool so deep learn
Jess or as it's called now actually I
think they released it like last week
thank you google
it's called tensorflow jess now it's
like I said before they changed the API
so the code I'm showing you might not be
a 100% accurate but you can still like
if you can get the NPM package of deep
learn version 0.4 I think then you can
check out the repository then you get
the right version anyways
so deep lunges provides us with a way to
build neural networks and it's actually
kind of sort of really straightforward
so I'm hoping that you know I can show
you this and you can like do it for
yourself even though you know it's not
exactly like this anymore but so a
neural network like I said before it's
the network made of notes and we don't
look at each single node we look at
these columns of nodes and I said before
each one little note and we have like
different columns and they can have a
different number of nodes doesn't really
matter just matters that it's a single
column
they can't have like weird other shapes
it's just has to be comes and then you
have this blue input basically in the
green output so the input is our
features the output is our prediction in
this case we only have two output notes
but that's just because I've do it this
way and the important thing to
understand is that each node is
connected to all the other nodes in the
next layer and the ligands that each
node connected to all the other nodes
they're not connected like in the same
layer always to the next one
right so let's look at one single note
to try to understand what's happening
there so in this case the snow like the
layer before has three notes the layer
after it has to be notes and we're just
looking at one node in this layer and
we're getting our inputs from the layer
before and those are like three
different values and kind of like doing
something with them like adding them
together to create one output and we
output this same value to all the other
notes so we receiving three different
inputs but we're outputting the same
value and now you will think for
yourself like okay we're just adding all
the inputs then all the nodes in this
layer will output the same value this is
kind of how the magic of machine
learning works is that each node has
these weights
it has like a parameters for each of
those inputs to define how important
this input is to understand this pattern
so maybe if we have come to the
complementary color prediction one of
the inputs is let's say the weather
today then hopefully the system will
kind of learn that this is a very like
doesn't really matter this input and
like will give it a very very small
weight so once you multiply it it
becomes like almost you know it doesn't
matter in your in your sum in the end
that's kind of the idea so by that
that's the magic basically of neural
networks so the weights are property of
the node so they're not property of the
input they're like that the node has the
weights and you have one weight for each
input to define how important that input
is and all the weights in one network
that those basically represent your
model because that's basically what your
model is it tells you like of all the
inputs those are the how important are
the inputs and then I'm going to
calculate them and then I can give you
like a value in the end that kind of
tells you the probability of what you
want to predict what's going to happen
or complimentary colors or whatever you
want to predict so we need a weight
those are the most important things all
right in deep lunges or tens of logic
the columns of a network are represented
by a thing that's called tensor so a
tensor is a layer it's just one column
and the reason why it has to be columns
as because we're doing a lot of vector
and matrix multiplication and that is
also why machine learning is so powerful
because we can do a lot of calculations
in parallel with that and can do like
can go over a lot of data in pretty
short amount of time so yeah that's why
we need columns and rows where each
column represents basically a layer and
a row represents the data set I'm going
to explain that later don't yeah
everything's gonna come together in the
end I promise
all right tutors we have do two
different kinds of tensors the one kind
as a placeholder where okay we need a
name for that which is just like to find
it basically and then we need a size so
we have to know how many nodes have to
be in this placeholder and we need a
placeholder to input static values or
output like static values basically for
example for our input and target tensor
so this is how the code looks we as deep
learn the the library to give us a graph
because the graph is where we get all
our fancy tensors and everything from
and then we have like this placeholder
that is input tensor so that's where we
put in our features and the target
tensor this is where we put in our
desired output what we want it to and
since those are fixed values we know
them from the data set that we created
and those are placeholders the other
kind of Tenzer is called in this case I
call fully connected layer basically
okay we need a name again we're the size
again but here we need to give the fully
connected layer an input layer so it
knows which layer has to connect to and
it's called fully connected because like
I've explained before the node is
connected to all the nodes of the of the
next layer you can have like different
kinds of connections but I'm just gonna
show you like the super basic one
basically
and so this code goal is might look a
little bit complicated we're starting
with this with our input tensor this is
this is the input tensor for this
function where we add like a new
connected layer I'm gonna show you the
code for the function in a minute just
want to show you that we take this input
tensor adding another layer then adding
another layer they never layer and then
we're adding last layer which is our
prediction and these are the ending
indices for our layers just saying like
this is the first one the second one and
so on and these are the note sizes the
prediction gender of course again has to
be three nodes because we want like
three values RGB and this is what the
code looks like so again we have to call
the graph to give us this like dense
layers we're giving it a name giving it
the input layer so where are the inputs
coming from from layer before and then
layer size okay this is an activation
function normally in the layer all you
have to all you do is multiply each
input with its weight and then adding
that together this is a super simple
activation so if you if you hadn't have
a activation function if this was
undefined you would just get the result
from the calculation I just explained to
you once you have an input activation
function X is basically the result of
you know the multiplication to sum and
then we pass it here this function it's
called rectifier linear unit blah blah
blah all it does is if X is smaller than
zero it outputs zero and if X is bigger
than zero
it's just outputs takes it just sounds
and then this is the bias
boooooo we need a bias here because in
case we get a zero here
the next layer would think that the node
before was not activated because it's
getting a zero but we want the node to
be activated no matter what because
otherwise it would just basically think
that there was no no door it's like
really unimportant but that's not what
it is it's just like unfortunate we just
got a zero they have to add a bias
that's just adding plus one to the end
of the calculation so we know that the
node was activated it's really not that
like it's not that important if we're
just gonna build stuff and we're just
gonna put bias yes because someone told
me that bias is good like in machine
learning not in real life all right
let's go through a checklist again as I
already forgotten what I was talking
about so we have our data we now build a
network now we have to do something
awesome and then we're gonna have
something awesome right so let's talk
about this awesome thing we have to do
what like do you have an idea what we
have to do now we have our network we
have our data what do we think anyone
have an idea yes yes very good yes we
have to train our network because it has
to become better so how do we do this
let's just think about it like very high
level e very abstract we need to kind of
find a metric that tells us how good it
is how good our machine is predicting
right now
then we're gonna change something and
then we're gonna check the metric again
that's how how we kind of be better
that's kind of how I learned things you
know I was like I got like feedback
changed something like I'm on the right
track so let's talk about this metric
thing so we I call it cost loss or cost
or loss and I'm trying to explain this
graph to you so this is the x-axis which
is our input there's just a measure
which only have one input value right
now and this is the output value that we
have so I'm showing you this it
basically means this is a model or like
a system a pattern where when we input a
hundred we're gonna get an output of
like let's say a hundred
not seeing that really well we input
like 40 we're gonna get like I don't
know 40 something and then if we input
like 200 we're gonna get like a hundred
and twenty maybe so this is our reality
that we're trying to approximate and
this is our prediction this is what our
network is predicting right now so what
that means is that the distance between
the actual target value and what we
predicted for this X that distance is
our costs for our loss that's like how
far we are away from the actual correct
prediction or correct result or Target
and so because we're not like doing all
the calculations sequentially but like
parallel the cost function is all the
distances all the distances for all the
XS that we have that's our cost for this
model all right so if we want to
implement it and deep learn GS
all we have to do is find like choose an
algorithm in this case I'm gonna choose
mean squared error and you don't have to
understand what it does if you're
interested do the machine learning
course because it gets kind of masked
see you know don't really have the time
to explain it right now so we need an
algorithm and then we need the target
Tenzer and the prediction tensor makes
sense because we have to like calculate
the difference like the distance between
those two so calculate distance between
what we want to have and what we
actually have and then feed it in like
some kind of function I am a mean
squared error what it does is basically
it squares the error so big error will
always be like even more ridiculously
big will make the loss even greater than
like a smaller one squared so then the
implementation or the code is actually
super simple and deep learn we're just
calling the graph and say oh give me
mean squared cost that's the function
I'm calling and then we passing in the
target tensor and the prediction ten-ton
pretty simple right and the next thing
we need to talk about is the thing that
actually changes
values that actually so we have this
metric right and then the next thing was
the we need to change something to
change something on our network we need
this thing that dbrand calls an
optimizer so in this graph the x-axis is
the weight and the y-axis is the loss so
in if I show you this it kind of it
means that when the weight for our one
input is like 60 the loss is about like
30 if we have a weight of like 200 the
loss of the ball like 80 something and
it seems like if like a weight is around
a hundred and this is the like the
smallest loss we can have so this might
be the point where a weight should be
because like one small loss right right
so when we start up a network the weight
are always initialized randomly or they
always should be initialized randomly
when we start out anywhere and then what
the optimizer does is use the magic of
math to kind of take steps and try to
get to the approximate the the point
where the loss is less basically it's
like a little more complicated than that
but the way that we can imagine is that
we're just taking steps towards
hopefully the minimum and the the closer
we get to the minimum the smaller the
steps become as well so this is kind of
what we're doing when we're machine
learning with DJs so for the optimizer
to implement that we need an algorithm
again I'm just picking the algorithm
that's called gradient descent which is
which is doing what I just showed you
there are other optimized algorithms but
again I will like suggest to you that
you just look into it yourself and then
we need a learning rate the learning
rate is just the parameter it's a number
that determines how big these steps are
so this is a small learning rate and
this is a big learning rate in this
example it kind of looks like the bigger
learning rate is a problem because we
move away from the minimum could be a
problem it's just something that you
kind of have to try out for yourself to
see which learning rate is best suited
for your problem
and again the implementation is or was
actually super simple we just had to
call deep learn and just say give me the
I don't know what the essence for but
give me the gradient descent optimizer
and then just pass in a learning rate
that is basically it so we already have
our data or network and now we set up
the training and all we need to do is
run now all of you I kind of look at me
like well so how does it work
actually I just yeah I understood what
you said but I still don't understand
how it works so I'm gonna try to show
you how it actually works in a super
nice diagram so we start out with this
this is our network and we have our data
all right we're feeding in our data into
our network so this is we're feeding it
into the input and then you know a
compute staff blah blah blah and then it
outputs three that's our prediction then
we look into our data again and be fine
out the target was actually two so what
we had I have to do is calculate the
distance in this case I'm just using
subtraction I mean it's not what I used
before like I said it was another
algorithm was in this case to make it
simple the cost is just one it's just a
difference then we're feeding this one
into our optimizer what's the optimizer
does is take the one and then magically
goes back through the and network and
changes all the weights so when we go
from the input to the back it's called
forward propagation because we propagate
all the data forward and then what the
optimizer does is called backwards
propagation because it propagates values
backwards the difference is when we do
forward propagation we take like actual
inputs like the feature inputs
pass it through to make a prediction
when we do backwards propagation we're
not actually caring about input values
using the cost to try to change the
weights so we're not actually doing
anything with the prediction we just
like we just need the prediction to know
how good are our network is performing
and then taking that information and
trying to change the weight in a way
that it's going to perform better next
round so this is basically the entire
magic which I hope is not that
complicated anymore I hope it makes
sense to you now there's like like I'm
going to show some code on how to
generate the training data but it's the
important thing here so I'm like
generating a bunch of training data here
is that the input data and the target
data data are in two separate arrays and
the way that they're reference is just
by the index and they're like two
separate areas at the point and also we
don't push just like normal arrays
inside there we have to pull it like
these deep learn areas but like I said I
don't know I actually haven't looked
into how it works in tenza flow right
not like what you would have to call but
they actually have good examples for
that you can just check it out anyway so
it's not that important what's happening
here it's kind of just that we have to
put the training data that we generated
have to put it in this like shuffled
input provider so it would shuffle the
data for us but the reference is still
intact from the input to the target
that's basically all like this slide
shows all right so when we train it when
we run everything now that we have
everything it actually it doesn't look
that complicated anymore we have to
start a session and we passed this math
environment and math basically tells you
if you are in the browser you can
utilize the GPU if you're not in the
browser you have to use the CPU and you
know it's nice to have things need to be
you because the leg runs much faster and
then then you work with the CPU and then
on this math environment you call I'm
going to train this
okay on the session call train pass it
okay you need the cost tensor and you
need the feed entries which is the data
the batch size basically just
determining how many data points are we
going to iterate through right now the
optimizer you know it like it takes the
cost tensor and the network and then try
to like change things change the weights
and those last parameter is just we just
needed to output the cost the loss that
we have after each bedroom so this is
the code and the nice thing about you
know running in the browser is that you
can utilize all the nice browser things
like service workers and everything so I
spun up a little demo and I'm gonna just
show you the video right now cuz it
takes forever for to run actually so
like I said what we wanted to achieve
was to do a complementary color
prediction and in this case the input
color will always be this like slight
like light purple and this is our target
color this is the color that we want the
machine to predict this is the color
that the machine is predicting right now
this is completely randomly set up so it
could be any color it says cost zero
here but that's obviously wrong because
cos zero would mean that we have the
perfect prediction it should say cost
one but yeah I didn't fix it and I
thought it would be easier to just
explain to you that it's not correct
then should actually fix it so let's
take a look at this video so you can see
that it's like slowly like changing the
values and getting like better and you
can also see that the cost is getting
smaller and smaller
and then at some points I'm running like
a thousand patch this year I think so
I'm running a 25 batch size and doing it
I'll run a thousand batches and here at
the end I don't know how you feel about
it but I think it's like almost
indistinguishable the difference and if
you like if we look at the beginning it
starts all like with this and it like
really gradually very slowly kind of
like approximates the actual value and
but
every time you set it up it starts
completely randomly so I had to make a
video of like a nice run that actually
shows what I want to show but you know
you can like I said you can check out
the repository and just try it for
yourself this was one example from
Google but they've scrapped it with all
the with all the documentation and
everything so you kind of have to check
out my specific repository for still to
run all right some links for you to
check out so first of all that's the
repository I was talking about then
there's a deep learning j/s which is
apparently not deep Londres anymore but
it will take you to tens of florges
this is like a really nice explanation
no this is the demo which I don't
actually know if it's still up or not
so you have to see for yourself okay
this is a very nice explanation of from
deep learning fundamentals that I didn't
cover like what kind of activation
function should I use if you're
interested in that and oh it's the
phones I didn't put in the course so
Coursera is the platform and it's just
called Stanford machine learning course
alright and I have to show the slide we
are hiring we have offices in those
beautiful cities so if you are
interested and you know doing cloud
computing which has nothing to do what I
was just talking about you can talk to
me or just go to the website thank you
and then now that's
[Applause]